هناك وسيله واحده لانهاء هذه الحرب
الوسيله المنطقيه ان ينسحب بوتين من
اوكرانيا رقم واحد يبدو انه لن يفعل ذلك
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم الرئيس الامريكي يؤكد ان
انسحاب روسيا من اوكرانيا هو الطريقه
الوحيده لانهاء الحرب
عالم مواصله عملياتها العسكريه والمستشار
الالماني يدعو الرئيس الروسي الى سحب
قواته
يطالب برلين باعاده النظر في موقفها من
الحرب قصف تركيا على مواقع شماليه سوريا
وانقى تقول ان معركتها ضد من سمتهم
الارهابيين ستتواصلوا بشكل فعال وتطالب
حلفاءها بقطع الدعم عنهم وما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه تعلن تعليق التعاون مع
التحالف الدولي بسبب الاضراب حركه
القطارات في فرنسا تصاب بالشلال والشركه
الوطنيه للسكك الحديديه تلغي 60% من
رحلاتها اليوم العمال المطربون يطالبون
بزياده الاجور وتحسين اوضاعهم الوظيفيه في
ظل الازمه الاقتصاديه الحاليه
الماكينه الالمانيه تودع كاس العالم نشطون
المان عبروا عن غضبهم من الاداء الهزيل
الذي ادى الى الخروج من الدور الاول للمره
الثانيه على التوالي بعد مونديال روسيا
لعام 2018 بينما قال مغردون العرب ان
المنتخب كان مهتما بالمواقف السياسيه اكثر
من اللعب
[موسيقى]